qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé c'est bon tout va
bien rappelle-toi que ce sont ces
mercenaires qui ont tué ta
sœur on met la peur de côté et on se
concentre allez une mauvaise
nouvelle des régulateurs de pression
sont installés dans le gazoduc du champ
gazier de HL avec une seule détonation
porort de livraison du gaz les uns après
les
autres tous les gars son duc exploseront
jusqu'en Chine
bombe cette opération est illégale vous
dépassez les limites mes limites sont
plus éloignées que tu ne le penses vous
vous rendez compte de ce que vous venez
de
faire si tu t'avises encore une fois de
mettre mes frères en danger je te tire
une balle dans la tête commencez le
comptearbour
plus que 15 secondes allez allez
[Musique]
allez